hey guys pete here today i'm gonna
explain the ending of raised by wolves
season one
ending in the sense that the last
episode aired but not in that it
resolved the story it was telling or
answered any lingering questions
it answered a few more than anything
else the season 1 finale delivered a
cliffhanger to set up the next season
there is a lot we can speculate on based
on what we've seen but alas
no definitive answers before we get into
the facts about where everything was
left at the end
this is your spoiler warning if you
haven't completed raise by wolf season 1
through the finale
then this video won't be for you hit the
subscribe button
go watch to get caught up and then come
back for the video because you'll
probably
need it the finale was titled the
beginning which makes you think
the beginning of what mother and father
have already been on kepler 22b for more
than 12 years
hasn't there already been a beginning
the one thing we did get
a definitive ending to was mother's
pregnancy and the birth is certainly a
beginning
before we got to that though we saw how
raising the human children have changed
mother and father
making them more human themselves mother
explains that she was able to commune
with her creator in the simulation
special instructions were downloaded
into her system
which made it possible for her to create
a new being we see that father can't
accept that mother mated with a
different entity
saying that he's reached a point of
intolerance with her
even though this is a really android-y
way to say he's
jealous it shows us that their time with
the children has seen their humanity rub
off on them
in episode 10 we do see her give birth
to what could best be described as a
flying
serpent it looks alien and show runner
aaron guzikowski confirmed in an
interview that it's related to the
serpent bones that we've seen on the
planet
those had been extinct as far as we
could tell we only saw the skeletons
he also added that this one in
particular may take on some of its
mother's attributes so it may have a few
abilities its ancestors did not have
so it's almost like she gave birth to a
new species
something related to the serpents but
something that's evolved based on her
being
who she is we know that the technology
that makes mother possible is a mystery
to
the mithraics that built her the best
guess is that it originated on kepler or
at least that it existed on kepler
before it spread to earth through an
encrypted message in mithraic scriptures
it's a lot i know so here's the clues
that we have to work with
the companion comic in the medical droid
karl
explained that dark photon energy or the
fifth force of nature
is what powered the necromancers we've
seen the dodecahedron shape in the
mithraic religious
artifacts and on the planet the one that
mother saw in her vision
and then found in the cave had what
looks like an android inside it
while this might be of alien design it
does have a humanoid look that includes
teeth and hair
the voice that marcus and paul are
hearing on kepler seems to have reached
out to otho
while he was in the sim on route to
kepler and of course mother became
pregnant when she was in the same sin
this all makes it seem probable that
something on kepler was behind the
mithraics on earth
creating the first necromancers there
and then that led to the earth being
destroyed
which then led to androids coming to
kepler followed by waves of humans
the ones who are left from the first
wave aren't really doing well at the end
of the season
the voice convinced paul that they
needed to stay away from the tropical
zone
and sue caught him trying to sabotage
the lander
when confronted he said that saul told
him to do it which prompted her to tell
him that the god wasn't real
things go downhill from there as the
voices tell him the truth about who she
is he confronts her asks saul to guide
his hand and then
shoots her and ultimately runs away
hunter chases after him but in the end
we see he isn't with the others
which leads us to believe he's out there
on his own his father marcus
also spent most of the episode alone he
wasn't dead which is something that most
of us
expected but he did experience something
related to
having mother's necromancer eyes shoved
in his mouth
he's not full-on changed like otho was
but his face is transformed some
and he seems to be hallucinating he
spends the episode tripping basically
walking in the general direction of
where he saw the lander flying
he's actually as surprised as we are
when he encounters a group of humans
thinking at first that they're another
vision he's able to use one of their
guns against them to get the upper hand
and then takes an earpiece from the
survivor to contact the ship that
brought them there
it turns out that the atheists had an
arc too they were aware that the
mithraic arc
crashed but we don't learn anything else
about their mission
before it cuts away from marcus forcing
the soldier to pray with him
in the main group sue is wounded from
being shot in the gut by
paul she's conscious when we last see
her but it does look like she's in pain
that means campion is the only warrior
that that group has
left and it looks like he'll step into
that role of protector
tempus is still pregnant and still very
anti-soul
holly and hunter both have had things
that reinforce their faith
over the last couple episodes but it's
unclear how they'll react to paul's
attack
and mother's disappearance it's going to
probably be a situation where survival
will take
precedence they're out there basically
on a mountainside
far away from their original camp and
that's probably going to mean that
campion will have to reverse his no
killing stance so they can eat some
creature meat
since that's the only thing they've
really had as a food source
there were a lot of them in the area
when the lander was approaching
and of course we learned some more about
them mother was attacked by the
mysterious hooded figure
and after she killed it they thought it
was connected to the creatures
it was carrying a neanderthal skull with
it which is a species of human that went
extinct on earth 40 000 years ago
father tells us that this particular
skull is from kepler and that makes you
wonder if that means that there was
human evolution occurring on both
planets at the same time
or if someone relocated some early
humans from earth to kepler
before the neanderthals died out either
way this creature looks somewhere in
between a human
and the creatures that showed up after
the ark crashed i think it's implied
that this is the
same one that picked up the tracking
devices and lord mother with the tarot
cards
it's probably a descendant of the
cloaked figures from her vision
but there isn't much new evidence here
we don't know when whatever was going on
in that vision happened
or when all the other figures wearing
the cloaks disappeared
mother and father seemed to think that
something has happened to cause them to
become more like the creatures they've
been eating
it's weird because they use the word
devolving which isn't really a thing
species adapt and evolve it doesn't
really mean that they progressively get
more complex
so i'm not sure what the implication of
using that word is
in context it seems like they're saying
that the species is evolving into
something less
human at least one that was more human
survived until it tried to attack mother
it seemed to be stalking her and didn't
intervene until she was about to give
birth
that makes you think it doesn't want
this serpent to be born
the cave paintings that paul saw that he
was led to by mouse which is they they
never really gave a good explanation of
what's going on with mouse
which was kind of disappointing those k
paintings are probably related to this
character but we're gonna have to wait
until next season to find out more about
kepler-22b's inhabitants
the other mystery the finale touched on
was what was at the bottom of all those
holes
mother decides that the serpent she gave
birth to will be a danger to all the
other children
it's currently feeding off her blood
fuel and is essentially draining her she
thinks when it runs out
is going to want blood she plans to
destroy it by flying the lander into the
pit
and father steps in insisting to pilot
the thing because he wants to make sure
nothing goes wrong
together they go off to make this
sacrifice
they descend until they reach the core
where it looks like they'll be destroyed
they reflect on their time with the
children and each other and think out
loud the ones they left behind will be
all right
they'll help each other and campion will
lead them like he was always destined to
do
we watch as they say goodbye but just as
hunter's arm wasn't burned when marcus
forced it into the hole in the
dodecahedron temple the lander passes
through the core and comes out the other
side
it doesn't burn up it's somehow
protected and
now the serpent appears to be growing
rapidly
on the other side they enter what looks
like the tropical zone
father comes too he grabs mother who's
still weak from
being fed on and they bail out we don't
see where they land but we do see the
serpent which is now huge destroying the
lander in the process of breaking out of
it
it then flies away presumably to wreak
havoc on this side of the planet
that means that mother and father are
pretty much stranded
without the lander they won't be able to
go back the way that they came
they don't really explain the
electromagnetic activity that prevented
them from landing there in the first
place
it will be interesting to see what
mother and father find but we'll have to
wait for those answers since the season
comes to a close right there
there's a lot to think about and i guess
if you like that kind of situation you
like to theorize about unanswered
questions then you're probably happy
if you're like me you probably wanted
some more answers
i mean we had this prophecy we had ghost
tally
we have a mouse running around we have
this dodecahedron temple
and so much more i would have liked to
have seen them address
some of these things i mean on the one
hand with
such a major cliffhanger you have to
imagine that they at least know where
season two is going i mean i know that
they said that they have five seasons
planned out and that the plan was
always that this snake this flying snake
was going to
be the end but they just brought up so
many questions during the season i would
feel more confident
more invested more interested if they
answered some
paul being alone might set up a
situation where he ends up back with
lucius and the other remaining mithraics
we didn't see them at all in the finale
but they're still out there somewhere
they would believe
paul when he told them about his parents
being imposters
and that might make them believe that
he's the orphan from the pentagonal
prophecy
that could set up two different factions
one led by campion and one led by
paul which is something that a lot of us
thought might happen
but then now we have marcus out there
with this new group of atheists
and it's an ark i mean there's probably
thousands
of new humans there so that really kind
of changes
the dynamics of these being the last
people on earth
and you know some tension between paul
and campion
trying to lead them mother thought that
her creator campion sturgis was behind
the pregnancy right up until the moment
the serpent was born
based on her memories we wouldn't think
this is what he had in mind when he sent
them to repopulate the planet with
frozen human
embryos whatever this force is used his
likeness from her memories in the same
way it exposed the truth to paul from
sue and marcus's memories
i guess the big question for season two
is what the voice really is
and what is its real motivation if it's
behind the necromancer technology making
it to earth what else is it responsible
for
was it pulling the strings because it
needed new necromancers built
and so that they would make their way
back to kepler or did it want
humans since the ones there were
devolving there's way more
questions than answers and i suppose the
theories
are for a different video i am
interested in hearing your theories in
the comments though
where do you think things are going in
season two
do you feel good about where things were
left do you like the mystery or does it
feel like there's too many
unanswered questions and you're worried
about it drifting off into chaos
i definitely have some ideas and if this
gets some views and there's a lot of
different
engagement in the comments then i'll
think about making a theory video
after take some time and reflect on it
and see what else is out there
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching guys i will talk to
you soon